Every time they talk about lifting a blind,
Have you ever lifted a blind?
How dare you say
a lot of deputies that you don't even know
whether or not a blind has been lifted?
And how dare you make these cartoons?
You are not ashamed.
I myself,
your Honor,
have lifted the blind at 08:30.
Yes,
you will laugh less now,
miss,
at 08:30 in the morning,
with my father,
every day in its commerce,
accompanying him because I was going to kill him
the terrorist group ETA,
that I knew that every day I would lift the blind.
from your trade at 08:30
because they would kill him
its partners,
refers to a number of deputies from different groups
to say that they have never erected a blind here,
But what have you worked for?
I guess some may have done it,
But how dare they make such a cartoon?
This is the parliamentary level you are claiming.
and they come here and call the rest of the world a classist.
and you say so,
you who have refused
to accept Vox's proposal
to pay for the masks to all Spaniards
because there are Spaniards who already have to choose
between masks or milk.
Classist and sexist
is not to pay social security to your caregiver.
What do some deputies in your group do?